20 days here a long stretch without  being an Oracle Danny Green quickly  fires and hits the free corner  [Applause]  ball deflected picked up by Leonard get  any green wide open allow the play to  develop so he forces Bogut to be in  position to help it creates the wide  open shot Danny Green head fake  3-pointer is good and he greed with  three threes here the opening period  third team foul against Golden State  third on green Danny Green answers  [Applause]  planet pushing the pace kicks it out  Danny Green pucks it in Danny great from  downtown back-to-back threes then this  equals against Jordan Bell gets into the  paint against the black pine down gold  knocked loose and Leonard able to save  it  Danny Green for three Danny Green does  it again look here he just beats him to  the ball saves it and then a desperation  three by Green